[Music]
hey you guys
it's [ __ ] what day is it
tuesday
okay i totally spaced it out and forgot
what day it was i think it's tuesday
right yeah
i guess
but uh yeah if you hear noises outside
the landscapers that are out there whole
crew out there and they're right my
office is right over the garage which is
right by where they're working so if you
hear voices and banging and stuff like
that
down there that's what that is it might
throw us out of the damn show we don't
like the distractions but we've got to
get it done
no need for me too says [ __ ] starting
[Laughter]
it doesn't it doesn't help
the
anyway we saw we saw a pretty good movie
on netflix it's like made for netflix
movie had the rock in it
and um
it was pretty good it's pretty good it's
kind of like uh it's just kind of like
another big budget
action movie with the rock i had a lot
of comedy in it a bunch of [ __ ] happened
uh
had a bunch of elements from like
raiders of lost ark and
mission impossible and it knew it you
know what i mean it's ape and then
ocean's 11 kind of had some oceans 11
vibe in there yeah
and it's uh they set it up for a sequel
kind of like they're making a new
property
but um
had some
some twists and turns in the story and
kind of turned out in an honest
unexpected way and it was good it was
good rock plays this cop and he starts
dealing with this guy as a professional
art thief
then there's a woman who's also a
professional arts thief they're trying
to steal these damn eggs they're trying
to get three of these eggs to cleopatra
that was
it doesn't it
historically the [ __ ] the movie
doesn't make any sense it knows it
doesn't make any sense it's kind of like
national treasure in that right did you
see that one with nicholas cage right
with the thing on the back of the was it
on the back of the declaration of
independence or some [ __ ] like that like
yeah like a treasure map on the back of
the declaration of it
it's you know cleopatra didn't have any
[ __ ] golden eggs made all right this
is all just well mark anthony made them
for her i think was the story because
they give you
at the very beginning there's like a
little prologue that's almost set up
like one of those kind of like history
channel documentaries that tells about
like the history of these eggs and marc
anthony made them for her and then one
of them
got found and was in a meet in is in a
museum in rome and then the other one
was found and is in like a private
collection and the third one was never
found which so that kind of plot plays
into it as well and the rom the eggs
don't look roman they don't even look
they don't even look old they look brand
new they're pretty snazzy though i guess
they look like something from the 1700s
though yeah they almost look like
[ __ ] 1700s french gold for days yeah
with jewels all over it i'm into it yeah
i like i like the opulence and then lost
not
lost nazi treasure gets involved and uh
see i like it yeah yeah yeah right
there's a lost art i like that they did
like the hitler bunker uh situation
there that's kind of cool i like that
yep but uh yeah i just the thing about
this movie okay i'm not entirely sure
like how the movie biz works exactly
this movie i don't think it was actually
made for netflix it was actually made
or at least the idea of it there was
like a bidding war uh for all the
different major studios right because
this was the idea for this was floating
around like a couple years ago they were
actually supposed to shoot it back in
2019
and then they shot some of it and then
it had to be like postponed because they
had to go to rome and because of covet
and all that other stuff so uh they
didn't finish shooting it until 2020 and
then they were gonna release it in
theaters but then netflix
um and universal and legendary like went
in and bought the rights to it so this
actually did get a theatrical release it
came out in the theaters
in
november like this past november okay
and then a week later it went to netflix
i never even heard of it i hadn't either
and the only reason we came across it i
had because we have amazon prime we have
hulu we have shutter we watch to be so
netflix i usually only check it like
every now and then when i remember and i
was chat and i was on there the other
day because i've been watching um
archive 81 and i went on there to watch
an episode or so of that and then we
were scrolling through and tom's like
hey there's a movie with the rock in it
and we should watch that and i hadn't
even heard of it even though i
discovered today
this movie uh recently unseated bird box
as the most watched movie on the
platform
in its first three days and i think like
the most because you know how netflix
doesn't tell you bird box they they kind
of tell you how many
uh households need to watch it
like for them to presumably make their
money back but they don't tell you how
that's calculated
um but yeah i think they said well 83
million households or something like
that like have to watch this for them to
like make it back but it it was like a
[ __ ] on more than that so this i believe
as of now this is the number one most
viewed that may not be saying movie on
netflix it may not be saying much like
ever bird box what the hell's bird box
yeah i saw it yeah yeah it was it was a
horror movie it was a horror movie all
right um based on a novel by josh
mallorman yeah that was probably that
was a couple i don't think november was
a real good month for movies either
this made a couple million at the
theater but it was just like i said it
was only released like
limited
um because pretty much netflix were kind
of like i think they paid this was also
the highest that they'd ever paid for
they could they paid like 200 million
for this [ __ ] okay or that's how much it
cost to make i'm not entirely sure how
that worked out but they paid like a lot
of money for that i mean it's definitely
a high this is a very very expensive
looking movie yeah i will say it's
definitely a big budget movie oh yeah
big time it's like fast and furious or
something yeah and it's not deep it's
not
clever or anything it's just a funny
[ __ ] action movie with a bunch of
crazy [ __ ] that happens in it very
entertaining
uh you're not supposed to be thinking
about this too much
it does have good uh
special effects it's got good acting
it's got the rocks [ __ ] awesome in it
like he always is i mean he's always
awesome he just kind of stands there the
rock is the rock
he consistently plays that character
yeah that's okay though that's fine um
that's what people are paying to see
yeah
oh as we were watching it i'm like and i
[ __ ] i don't like to say this i don't
like to com compare one
person to the next all the time you know
when it comes to the arts
um but i'm watching this i'm going like
man
the rock is so much better than [ __ ]
arnie oscar is already uh disagreeing
with you oh really
[Laughter]
there were certain roles that arnie
would [ __ ] you could not replace
arnie in a lot of those roles like you
could never replace arnie in the
terminator or that way or predator one
yeah or [ __ ] commando or um
[ __ ] conan that
there are just certain iconic roles that
were just [ __ ] perfect for arnold
schwarzenegger
arnold was not really he did not come
across as like a real
guy or like a real
friendly person or he never came across
as being like
a real person yeah he thought he's a bit
robotic yeah he plays a good robot or a
good villain or a good uh he's not the
kind of guy you want to hang out with in
these movies
you know and probably in real life
either yeah you don't really want
even though he's [ __ ] great in some
movies and they came back with maggie he
acted in that one he's i was actually
impressed that was probably his best one
when it came to acting so he did get
better
but um the rock always comes across as
somebody who you'd like to hang out with
well it's not already never really came
out you want to see arnie
but you have the impression that you
don't really want to hang out with him
too long right even though in real life
that's not the way he was a lot of
people said that he was he was addictive
to be around it just didn't that he was
like kind of funny yeah it didn't come
across on screen didn't come across on
screen sometimes it doesn't right but in
real life a [ __ ] arnie they say he
was just addictive
you know what i mean to be you you'd
hang out with him you didn't want to
stop hanging out with him because he was
in real life he's a [ __ ] total clown
and a [ __ ] real smart ass and just
[ __ ] hilarious
and i think he only get a little bit of
that from the from the documentary
pumping iron
that's more like how he how he is he's a
clown oh and oh and here's the thing
arnie comes out and says [ __ ] about
[ __ ] politics and people get madness
you can't take and about be a veganism
no you can't take [ __ ] artie
seriously man the dude's a clown he was
always a clown he'll troll the [ __ ] out
of people it just seemed real serious
he's not serious he's not a serious guy
he's glad
you know so i was just saying that you
know because i don't know
a lot of people think that he has
gravitas he doesn't
yeah arnie's a crime
oscar says uh the rock can't act dave
bautista is far better i like dave
bautista too uh the rock well the rock
axe he he asked himself but he always
acts like himself but like i said i if
i don't have a problem with some actors
like that if that if the person that
they're being is cool yeah um yeah the
rock kind of just plays himself in every
role but that's like i said that's what
you want to see because he seems like
and what i was gonna say was that the
rock has kind of like a charm and a sex
appeal
that arnie never really nod no the rock
comes off as a sexy guy you can
understand that [ __ ] women would be
attractive to him arnold himself knew
that he was not a sex symbol really in
that way
guys liked him more than women did
you know
yeah there's just something like not
yeah not all that there's he doesn't
have a lot of sex appeal not on screen
not really but uh women that knew arnie
like his girlfriend said that he just
was he was like catnip
you couldn't stop hanging around with
him he was
sexy in person just not on screen yeah
but i mean that happens i mean and like
i said everybody's got their own
thing right that they're doing and that
was his thing and he was good at that
now
uh there are there is one movie that
does come to mind that the rock [ __ ]
kills it and he is acting and that was
that one florida that one true crime
story here in florida was it called
painting game oh yeah painting that one
where he played like that big jesus
freak he plays a jesus
[ __ ] guy a religious bodybuilder
that's what it was based on that the
real character was a guy in a gym he was
a big old bodybuilder and he was just
way way off into jesus
and he gets involved in this damn crime
and if you haven't seen pain and gain
man [ __ ] it's it's a masterpiece and
that's a michael bane movie in it
i can't remember now i think it might
have been in his name michael bain
bae yeah he does all the transformers
and [ __ ] he does all that all the
explosions i'm not a [ __ ] boomer all
right i'm [ __ ] gen x but i act like a
boomer like yeah michael baron yeah yeah
he does that's like not most of these
people are like
i've i've known him for like 11 or 12
years like i think within like uh six
months of knowing him i was like you
kind of sound like my grandpa yeah
who died in 1991
well the weird thing the thing is we do
this show and a [ __ ] commentary
i'm a goth dude i don't really give a
[ __ ] about [ __ ]
mainstream culture and celebrities i
mean there's certain one guys that do
stand out certain women that do stand
out i like their [ __ ] and there's
certain directors that do stand out but
a lot of them i don't give a [ __ ] about
i i just don't get to [ __ ] about them um
some of them do have artistic qual
qualities that that i appreciate other
ones are just cash grabbers in a
corporate system they're
interchangeable and um
bae is like that he knows how to make
big
blockbusters
which is fine if you want if you want to
see that i mean i'm not really into
those but i'm not going to [ __ ] them
because everybody likes different [ __ ]
yeah i mean they make a lot of money and
that's what movies are out there really
yeah a lot of people like those
obviously that kind of movie it's
designed from the ground up to make a
[ __ ] ton of money
uh now the one he did one that wasn't
designed for that and it was called pain
and gain and it's [ __ ] great it's
[ __ ] great
it is and it's i like it nothing like
his other movie it's a comedy but it is
a pitch black comedy it's based on like
a real crime right and it really [ __ ]
up currently and the rock's got a big
role in that one um and um
you don't hear him talk about that movie
that much because
he is playing another character in that
one i realized that no the rock can act
you can act yeah
it's just that's not what they're hiring
it's just that usually i mean usually
you want to see him like in like in
jumanji or something like that you just
want to see him be in the rock or like
in uh fighting with my family where he
essentially where he played himself
but um you know that's what you want to
see because he just seems like such a
fun-loving charming dude and so that's
kind of what you're paying the ticket
price to see and i think that this movie
in particular the reason why there was
such a massive bidding war
and if you see it you'll understand why
is because this is
and you know you can say that this movie
was cynically calculated to make as much
money as possible that
you know that would probably be true but
it's still like a really entertaining
movie it's like you got the rock you got
ryan reynolds who's probably like one of
the biggest [ __ ] stars in the world
uh you got uh gal gadot who was your
wonder woman
and uh so you have these three [ __ ]
huge massive stars and they're going to
fly them all over the world they're
going to rome they're going to bali
they're going like all over the [ __ ]
place and it's just this massive like
heist fun action
buddy cop movie essentially
um has element of 48 hours we got a cop
with a with a prisoner basically they're
doing all this [ __ ]
but the thing is though is that it
everybody's being [ __ ] playing the
type in this movie yeah and all of a
sudden
it gives you [ __ ] whiplash you find
out that it wasn't what you thought it
was which i thought that was brilliant i
did like that and honestly i didn't see
it coming because the movie like i said
it's nothing you haven't seen before
it's kind of but it knows that it's very
self-aware uh it knows that it's
essentially being like ocean's 11 or
raiders of the lost ark and and they're
making like a lot of snarky like inside
jokes about this ryan reynolds is being
ryan reynolds if you don't like deadpool
or you don't like anything like that you
probably will not like this because ryan
reynolds is being it's essentially being
dead bull uh but but that's kind of what
he does although he's in some
he was in a great movie called the
voices i think we talked about where he
was kind of more of a
more of a subdued kind of part so he can
do that but again this is one where the
movie they wanted ryan reynolds to do
the ryan reynolds stick you know what i
mean everybody's doing the stick they're
doing the stick yeah uh i will say the
cinematography in this gorgeous
uh the you know i love like all the
different locations i love [ __ ] about i
like heist movies i especially like
stuff about art heists because i'm
interested in that in real life like i
really like uh art forgery art heist i'm
really interested in that so i like that
aspect of it so uh they were hoping that
this movie would be really successful
because we see the end of this movie
which i won't spoil uh they are
obviously setting up a sequel and i
think
netflix
i think they're they were hoping that
this would be successful so they could
have like a fast and the furious type of
franchise
uh so you can tell that they're kind of
trying to set that up again you could
say it's like a cynical cash grab but
it's still like an enjoyable movie so
i'm not too mad about it
uh so i guess that
this was successful enough that as of
this month well as of january
uh netflix greenlighted two sequels and
they're gonna shoot them like at the
same time like or back to back uh so
this is essentially gonna be like a
trilogy i guess unless something happens
uh after that because yeah they set up
at the end
they're gonna do another heist you know
what i mean but do we even say like what
the story of this is
we probably didn't yeah so here and
there talking about arnie [ __ ] danny
hasn't seen a racer eraser sucked man i
have it on blu-ray i didn't like it i
did not like eraser i um i liked true
lies although i think i liked it better
the first time i saw it than when i
rewatched it eraser i didn't like um end
of days i really didn't like yeah and i
saw that in the theater and i i even
didn't like that the first time i was
just kind of like oh my god this is
[ __ ] stupid but um
the last of the last of the
traditional
big arnie flick
you know we're talking about
you know along the lines of terminator
or uh [ __ ]
what was the one [ __ ] total recall
um
running man the last one like that that
he did i think was called sixth day or
fifth day i don't remember about the
genetic engineering i have it on blu-ray
it's [ __ ] great
yeah i did like that that was the last
of the archetypal
arnie flick
and it had a lot of the people that were
on the old army aren't at arnie flicks
and michael rooker was in it
uh [ __ ]
it was pretty good it's about cloning
it was kind of like
kind of like
uh [ __ ]
it was just like it was just like one of
the old-school arnie flicks kind of
reminded me of uh what was one where he
goes to mars if i could get your ass
back tomorrow uh just
like kind of like total recall but about
cloning
and um
you know he made movies after that they
were pretty good
the last stand was okay
maggie had good acting in it i liked
maggie a lot actually the one about the
plane crash what was it called damage i
think was called damage uh no aftermath
after math that's why that one was
[ __ ] weird too he played a villain in
that one i actually quite like i i like
when he plays a villain yeah to be
honest with you i think he makes a good
villain he gave up on the on his band to
be in villains because it probably would
have ended his career if they if he was
always a villain
because he was a great villain well once
you get kind of like especially dudes
like when you get like old and crotchety
i mean it's probably easier to play
villains i always thought i mean i'm not
an actor but i've you know pretty much
every actor has said that it's always
like more interesting to play villains
yeah
now one of the things about i think it's
called six day or fifth day i think one
of the reasons why i didn't get rated
too well i think by hollywood because if
i remember correctly it had some subtle
christian overtones
which would put it remember we're
talking about some
where christian movies were good and
when most of them sucked
that one i would call a good christian
movie because it was about anti-cloning
and souls remember that yeah
i didn't get too much of like real stuff
yeah they didn't do it wasn't like in
your face which is probably why no it's
real subtle because there ends up in the
end of that one there being two arnolds
and uh they let them live because they
had souls that's right remember that
that was the yeah yeah like i said it
wasn't it wasn't obnoxious though no it
wasn't obnoxious and like i said we've
talked about this before like you know
you could call the exorcist a christian
movie yeah but it's not
obnoxious about it and it's still a good
movie in its own right it's not trying
to push an agenda necessarily right and
also all of the damn um [ __ ] um
the final conflict and uh was that
series when they ended with the final
comment the omen the whole omen series
was a christian
series
you know so it can be done well it's
just that a lot of [ __ ] like pure flicks
and [ __ ] they don't have
talented directors and
too preachy and uh to cookie cutter
not artistic enough you have to be
are
kind of
artistic and you have to be kind of
neutral about certain things you know
noah darren aronowski [ __ ] awesome
flick
man that's like watching prometheus or
something but alien movie
yeah
you really need to see um
requiem for a dream all right
i mean
uh i will it's a it's a pretty
soul-crushing movie though so
you probably won't want to watch it
twice
because it's a big bummer but uh ellen
burstin from exorcist is in it uh
jennifer connolly is in it uh it's
depressing but it's really really good
it's actually visually really cool but
anyway uh okay so let me get back to
this movie okay
so
uh
now i just totally like lost my place
okay so so the rock
plays
uh a dude named john hartley a special
agent
and he is tracking
this
big time art thief
number
the second best art thief in the world
right uh played by ryan reynolds and i
can't remember what's what's his what's
the art thief's uh booth that's right
his last name is booth
so at the beginning they have this whole
thing where they explain what
cleopatra's eggs are and yadda yadda and
then uh so the rock is in rome
and
he's like
uh saying okay well booth is gonna come
steal the egg that's here and so then
there's kind of like a big chase
actually the the chase in the first part
like in the hote in the hotel in the
museum in rome was kind of like the the
scaffolding
thing at the beginning of casino royale
did you notice that i'm pretty sure they
were imagine casino royale there so
there's a lot of homages to other films
in this like i said there's nothing
super original about it no well then
they but yeah they'll hit they'll hit
a fake riff
in the soundtrack to let you know
they're talking about [ __ ] like yeah a
couple times away
yeah yeah mission impossible or like
ryan reynolds like whistling the uh
indiana jones theme at one point like
when they were going down into the nazis
yeah so it's it's very like aware of
itself
um it's giving you what you want though
yeah it's giving you it it's bending
over backwards to give you what you
wanted in in a playful way so it's great
i thought was great yeah so so yeah so
he tries to get like uh he tries to
catch when the guy gets away
and then uh the rock gets set up
by the number one art thief in the world
played by gal gadot who's going by the
name of the bishop
and so she has him set up and so him and
ryan reynolds are put in the same prison
cell
in russia
and they decide well we're gonna bust
out of here and
you're gonna help me catch the bishop
and all
like in exchange for me letting you go
and then you'll be the number one art
thief in the world because she'll be in
prison so then they have to like work
together and they really don't
like each other you know what i mean so
it's kind of like your standard buddy
cop
kind of uh set up where he's supposed to
be like this real upright fbi agent and
ryan reynolds just this snarky
wisecracking guy who does not like to
work with anybody ever so
that and they're kind of like uh schtick
like back and forth is actually pretty
funny uh so i do like that that kind of
aspect of it they played along with each
other very good but yeah so it's just
this kind of fun globe-hopping
heist movie with just them like sniping
at each other the whole time which you
know if that sounds like something you
would like it's you know it's not super
original but it's just fun you know well
it's on it's on netflix now and the
[ __ ] you know it's worth seeing if
you if you have the service then watch
it it's good flick yeah like i said it's
just a fun
turn your brain spoil it though that's
that yeah because it's new it's new yeah
yeah
okay jake adams this is the raw deals
one of the best arnold's movies they'll
say no it is not no i haven't seen that
since i was excited i have all of
arnie's movies on blu-ray with the
exception of uh
of um
true lies there's no blu-ray release for
that um
just dvd
and i have i have uh raw deal on blu-ray
it's a boring movie not well written
it gets better towards the end when he
when when he starts shooting the place
up what's that one about
he's an undercover cop in it
okay that's not really there
for me he penetrates some kind of
organization and that's it
it's it's very dry the acting isn't good
the writing isn't that good it just ends
in a pretty good action scene at the end
um
okay for instance like
it could never hold a candle to [ __ ]
commando commando's like [ __ ] five
times that
and but that one's not one of his good
ones it's just it just came out at a
certain time and when arnold was big and
people watched it
i think i saw it in the drive-in
and
i saw it on cable but i don't remember
anything about it and then uh there's
not much to it
uh trying to think uh somebody else said
something about arnie in here
adriana c says watch requiem for a dream
after watching dead ringers and i was in
a soul-crushing state for a month oh
yeah i can imagine yeah they're talking
about um
uh total recall
i get into a [ __ ]
fight every time a little swole about
total recall that's his favorite movie
too
you guys realize that [ __ ] um
that arnie's tripping in that right what
what is his name in the movie [ __ ]
quaid i think his name is quaid
quaid is tripping uh
he's uh no quaid was his character's
name i don't remember what his name was
before he went in he's still back at
recall he never left he got the he got
the vacation he paid for
none of it happened
every seriously every time we see lil
swole he kind of because there's a flip
smile yeah they end up in this
discussion what about the sweat on his
breasts
no no
because i can hear them like on the
other side of the bar and i was like are
they arguing about total recall it's
phillips dicks
phillip dicks and [ __ ] in philip k
phillip k dicks and he he he wrote the
story and it was called uh [ __ ] uh we
can get it for you we can remember it
for you wholesale yeah we can remember
for you wholesale and it is it is about
a company that sells you memories
because you can't
you can't afford it but see those kind
of movies are always the mind [ __ ]
because you never know and that's kind
of like what's cool about them is the
ambiguity because if somebody implanted
memories in your head you would never
know yeah you know what i mean and
there'd be no way of knowing it well not
really the meaning of the story is that
it doesn't matter yeah well yeah that's
what i'm saying it's the reality that
you know
yeah and so it's real for you yeah was
it real
no no he's back at reef call they gave
him they gave him the the they gave him
the fantasy that he paid for
now was he having the embolism and he
couldn't come out of it no
no that was just part of the ego trip
they bought
because they told him that he would 100
believe it
so all that damn plausible deniability
and him flipping it around and the
secret agents and him with the [ __ ]
embolism and everything that was all
just committing to the belief
but uh well yeah because you'd think for
people to keep coming back and buying
that service yeah it would have to be as
good as possible so they would have
winnowed it down to everything that made
everything seem as completely realistic
as possible yeah they gave him the woman
that he shows in the very beginning you
get remember he selected what kind of
woman he liked uh and in the in the end
he [ __ ] found he saved
mars saved earth
saved the [ __ ] found the alien
artifacts just all that [ __ ] [ __ ] he
got exa that he was a secret agent he
got everything he paid for
danny rolling ghostface says i can't
stand ryan reynolds at all okay well if
you can't stand ryan reynolds i will say
then you will hate this movie because he
is
brian reynoldzing the [ __ ] out of the
movie yeah um
so if you don't like then don't watch
this because it will just annoy the [ __ ]
out of you i don't mind it like i said i
don't i don't mind it uh his his thing
so it is it is a little much sometimes
but that's okay uh and then he says
except for the ryan reynolds film where
he's schizophrenic and lives above a
bowling alley which was a good film yeah
the voices that's
that's the one that i was talking about
earlier uh i think sophie sent us that
actually and we reviewed it we did a
matinee on that a while back yeah i
really really like that one a lot but he
was like a lot more subdued in that in
this one he's essentially just like
deadpool without the suit on yeah so
cool 122 said that conan was his best
movie
um
conan was a [ __ ] masterpiece you can
learn a lot from the story from the
story of conan that's that's uh one of
my best
one of the best directors of all times
um
and uh [ __ ] that that's like the
how-to manual for
how to be a badass and uh how to make a
man how to make a man out of your
[ __ ] man movie all that damn
philosophy okay now is that the best
arnold schwarzenegger movie no but it's
up there it's up there it gets to a
certain point where one's not better
than the other they're just among the
greats
and his greats are
conan
predator one
terminator one
commando terminator two now i personally
don't like terminator 2 but a lot of
people like it it is a good movie it
just i like it i just don't like that
kid yeah i don't like edward for a long
time yeah in it right i mean i'm sure
he's uh he's i'm sure he's fine in real
life it's just i don't like him in that
video that movie was the beginning of
the end of the terminator franchise they
made some mistakes with that
should have never made arnie the
should never made the terminator the
arnie character a [ __ ] good guy in
that one no he had to be he was just so
much better as a villain yeah it's just
should have sent me another [ __ ] bad
guy who looked just like that
that's all they had to do yeah another
robot that looked just like that that's
all they needed i mean you know but he
didn't want to play villain roles i know
that's like well that's on like i get it
but contracts and [ __ ] at that time i
get it because yeah if you're an actor
that gets typecast into playing villains
right you know you just play villains
forever and you don't really become a
star star you need to be like a leading
man
arnold's best roles or roles where he
would play morally ambiguous characters
that i think he was kind of gray yeah
was gray he wasn't
he wasn't it wasn't white or black and
he was it was a synthesis of good and
evil he was going beyond good and evil
which is a
nichian
concept power
you know and then how to use it wisely
that's that was what the
the uh that story was about
yeah jake adams said arnie and conan was
only good because of the director that's
why the sequel was not so good yeah yeah
the sequel was uh it had its moments but
well they dumbed it down for kids
yeah and really they should have spent
some more money on the special effects
yeah that movie would have been a lot
better
if they
hadn't had those stupid boss fights with
dudes in [ __ ] rubber costumes
it's been a lot better well yeah but
that was the problem the boss fight you
could fix that movie if you were to just
cgi a real good action scene instead of
that stupid ass [ __ ] dude with the
lizard head
you know [ __ ]
in a room full of mirrors that's [ __ ]
dumb
i mean it just looked so cheap it looked
really bad it just looked really cheap
it's like i could probably i could
probably shoot some better [ __ ] than
that in here that was the that was the
scene that ruined that movie
uh i got i want to go back and see red
sonja i don't have that one
that has arnie in it i kind of feel like
we were gonna watch that like the other
day and then like we forgot about it or
watch something else i said i had all
his movies i've actually i guess i lied
i don't have red zone oh you lying lied
[Laughter]
and i think there might be two of those
i don't know why we ended up talking
about arnold schwarzenegger when we were
talking about a movie with the rock in
it especially after after you said that
like you liked the rock more than
i think i like to rock a little bit
better on screen
but well like i said he kind of oozes
charm yeah
in a way that arnie didn't even though
the rock is all is not always in great
movies right he's always entertaining to
watch because he just seems like such a
nice dude and honestly like if you
follow him like on his social media and
stuff i don't but i've seen like other
people like post tweets and stuff and he
just seems like a really delightful
down-to-earth
person and he also always seems like
really enthusiastic like when some like
when one of his movies does well he's
always kind of like yay thank you thank
you guys blah blah blah so you know what
i mean he's like really cute like that
and he's kind of like geeky which which
i kind of dig or at least that's the
that's how he plays it there i think
there's a certain amount of act to the
rock character he's you know he's not
he's just on on the ball on his game
when he's yeah i mean sure that's right
i mean anybody that's that big a star
right um you know that would become a
character they're gonna yeah they're
gonna project a certain uh image you
know what i mean you kind of have to but
the rock doesn't have the rock doesn't
have any epic classic films you know
what i mean like [ __ ] terminator one
and [ __ ] yeah he's more a funny guy yeah
well another thing is is that iraq
appeared at a time when those move where
movies like that weren't having the same
impacts on society the competition was
more a bigger playing field and uh
things were going more to video games
just times were changing movies are not
as cool as they were
well it's crazy to me movies were like
that was all you had the more that i
read about this movie red notice i was
like i was amazed because this came out
and it was like a big huge deal on
netflix like every like it was in their
top 10 for like a month
and i only just now heard of it just
because i don't check netflix that much
and if i do check it then i usually just
check the horror section i usually check
horror and i check and see if there's
anything like any new like weird cooking
shows or
[ __ ] like that so i don't usually look
at like action adventure or anything i
usually just check horror
um
and
uh you know i like shows like movies
that made us and stuff like that if
there's new episodes of that that's like
all i check for so sometimes like some
big action adventure thing can come out
and 200 bajillion people can see it and
be talking about it and i haven't heard
of it and like all the famous people in
the world could be in it and i haven't
heard about it just because i'm kind of
so
yeah i'm so in my own little niche but
it's so easy to do that nowadays like
you know you can go off into your own
world now if y'all like
conan i was talking to you that liked
conan
if you liked conan that was john millius
you also want to see john muse's
amelia's other stuff stuff he was
involved in the one that came out before
that was robert redford and [ __ ]
jeremiah johnson [ __ ] that's like the
american conan
you know it's based on dude named liver
eating johnson all right who is
[ __ ] cannibal okay but that's part of
the it
came from a book called crow killer it
was about a guy out in the mountains
who uh
waged a one-man war against the crow
indians because they killed his wife who
was a flathead indian and
nobody knows how much these stories are
actually true for just legend i think a
lot of his legend because people could
lie a lot and it was hard to verify
um back in the back in the 1800s but you
want to see jeremiah johnson and then
the other one that milius was involved
in is you want to see uh the apocalypse
now
that's [ __ ] conan in vietnam
basically
all right
you want to see the long version the
director's cut oh yeah really good
well we've been watching uh rome the hbo
series yeah i bought it i bought it for
him for christmas it's great yeah and
that's yeah john millies was like the
cree show creator and producer of it
yeah show the history
very true it is actually one of the most
historically accurate
things about that period that i've ever
seen and it uh so far has been true to
what we know of roman culture and what
what has remained you know you can only
know so much because so much has been
lost since 2000 years but this
just kind of captures the vibe of the
era the thinking of the time
i like it we're not finished with it
we're about halfway through it
cool one two two one nine four says
watched hunter pray last night good
flick yes it is that's that's good i'm
glad you watched it yeah uh adriana c
says edward furlong was great in pecker
the john waters film i agree i don't l i
don't dislike edward furlong as an actor
because he has been in some good stuff i
just didn't like the character that he
played in t2 yeah i don't because i
didn't like and this was a problem with
a lot of more child teenage actors like
in the 90s
and it was movies tv everything i didn't
like that and i think bart simpson maybe
started it uh where all the kids had to
be like
you know smart talking like smart alec
and smarter than adults yeah and it's
just kind of and they were like all real
smug and big and they did like i just
[ __ ] i hated that whole the american
version of a japanese candy yeah i hated
i hated that whole thing and i and i
kind of feel like edward furlong
was real was like that like everyone was
so like over like edge lordy and
everyone was just kind of like oh god i
was like so over it like even back then
so it's like i did i liked t2 more but
back then but re-watching it i was kind
of like oh my god that kid's so [ __ ]
annoying there's a lot of cheese in the
t2 narrative too
where you have
basically
a waitress gives birth to a
revolutionary leader
she trains him as a boy
and has the ability to train him when he
was a boy because her boyfriend's was
from special forces
no that's not how that's not how that's
not how it works okay if he were to be
some kind of revolutionary general in
the future he would come from a
legitimate military organization or
would have fought his way up through a
military
organization that might happen but she
wouldn't have much to do with it that's
what i'm trying to say
it would be his life
created him
into that
and when you see how he's portrayed in
t2 that's exact opposite of what it
takes to be a military leader or to have
good military leadership skills you know
that yeah it's kind of
it was kind of the same thing that
happened like when they showed
uh you know anakin skywalker in the
prequels star wars it's like i don't
believe that that whiny little [ __ ] is
gonna grow up to be darth vader and it
was kind of the same thing here it's
like i don't believe that edge lordy
little [ __ ] is going to be like the
savior of the world in the future i'm
just not buying it right you know no
it'd be more likely that you'd be a
quiet little boy scout just watching
that's more likely
you've been kind of nerdy into dungeons
and dragons that type of stuff yeah see
i would that was now see that's a movie
i would have watched
i didn't i didn't need this kind of like
little delinquent child yeah no he was
mouthing off to everybody
[Laughter]
that usually doesn't end up being that
kind of person no i agree uh so maybe
that's what kind of bothered me about it
too i didn't buy it yeah
all right so uh you ready yeah yeah wrap
it up all right so yeah this movie uh
that we were talking about but off and
on
red notice uh if you like the rock if
you if i'm just gonna say and i'm gonna
mention this again if you don't like
ryan reynolds schtick
then don't watch it because he's doing
it in this uh so if you didn't like
deadpool or any of that then you
probably won't like this but other than
that it's just it's not super original
but
it's just a good time it's fun it has
like really fabulous locations and
fabulous like masquerade balls and all
that kind of stuff uh you know and it's
just like a fun movie so just have a
beer and watch it and
you know you know who would you know who
would have been a good example of who
could become a revolutionary leader or
darth vader the way octavian is shown in
that old series that rome series yeah
that kid which is a quiet boy who's real
intelligent adults can ask him something
he's like a human computer he can come
back remembering everything yeah see i
could buy that kid that's they're being
like darth vader right and they're like
hey go get laid and he's like i don't
know you know just he's just real shy
they they tend to end up real shy real
intelligent they tend to be they tend to
grow up being
leaders and darth vader's and [ __ ]
they tend to grow up being darth vader's
yeah yeah yeah yeah i could totally buy
that right that kid's actually really
good in that because they have they have
to start off having discipline yeah and
that's how they start off yeah nietzsche
talks about it okay so
uh i guess we'll wrap it up for today
tomorrow's wednesday so it's going to be
our regular show
and let's see what one in the poll
uh james ruppert and the easter sunday
massacre so we're going back to true
crime
so hopefully everybody's all excited
about that this was actually a case i
didn't really know all that much about
so i've read some about it and i'm going
to do like some more research later and
tomorrow and uh we will talk about it
tomorrow evening on the show so
have a good rest of your day you guys
and thanks for dropping by and we will
see you guys tomorrow evening